one of the things we talked about after
0.0 republicans in the house or senate
voted for joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar covid relief bill was
will these republican elected officials
who voted against the bill
that even many republican voters wanted
the the coveted relief bill remember had
about 70
support you don't get that with just
democrats that means independents and
republicans as well
we wondered will any of these republican
elected officials suffer consequences as
a result of voting against that
bill and we quickly saw even though they
all voted against it
some republicans publicly taking credit
for the fact that the bill was passed
and actually saying
it's good that people are getting this
or that or the other thing it's actually
even worse than this
a new poll finds that a third of
republican voters
believe that republican lawmakers
did vote for the covid relief bill
remember
nobody in the not a single republican in
the house voted in favor of the coveted
relief bill a couple of weeks ago
not a single republican in the senate
voted in favor of the coveted relief
bill one guy in the senate was missing
he didn't vote one way or the other not
a single one
and yet data for progress and vox
conducted a poll
of republican voters and 53 percent
knew that their republican lawmakers
did not vote for the bill but 31
said yeah they did vote for the bill and
17
didn't know that means that 48
of republicans um either wrongly
believed
that their elected officials voted for
the 1400
stimulus checks that most of them are
getting or simply didn't know one way or
the other now you might say well this is
probably a problem on the left as well
it is
but only to a fraction of a degree just
16 percent of democratic voters
thought republicans voted in favor of it
just 16 percent of independent voters
thought republicans voted in favor of
the coveted relief bill
so what you have here if if your if the
question you're trying to answer
is will there be repercussions for
republicans for voting against it
the answer is probably not number one
because the opportunity for
repercussions
is still almost two years away in the
2022 election
and number two because a whole bunch of
these republicans think
that their elected officials did vote in
favor of the bill
and this is exactly why i said there may
not
be that much of a political risk to
these republicans
for voting against because their
constituents still get the money
even though they voted against when it's
convenient they can say
i oppose the wasteful spending on
fill in the blank um and then they can
still get themselves re-elected because
their voters are completely clueless
now as far as the voters go
is this surprising not really
uh if you're able to be bamboozled into
thinking donald trump can fix
trade immigration health insurance
income inequality wages i mean you know
if you got tricked into that
then i could understand how you would
wrongly believe republican
senators and members of the house voted
for a bill they didn't vote for
if you uh fell for trump saying
the virus is just the flu and 15 cases
will be zero
and the covid vaccine could give you
covid and masks
are bad and don't work and a reflection
of
suppression of freedom and all this
other stuff as half a million people die
if you can fall for that stuff it's
pretty plausible to
believe that you will just wrongly
assess
whether your representative voted for or
against the coveted relief bill that
that's not really surprising
if you fell for biden's a socialist
biden takes over we're we're going to
have toilets you have to flush 15 times
and no windows and no heat and no air
conditioning and
it's all going to be socialism and
communism if you fell for that
this is like child's play this is this
is like nothing
so of course right wingers uh
mostly uh about 50 50 they wanted the
stimulus
most of them got it of course since most
of the country qualified for the 1400
checks they gladly accepted the free
money that counts as
socialism when they're hearing about the
things that joe biden is going to do
and in the end many of them a third of
them
and close to half of you include the
ones who don't know
think that their elected officials who
tried to prevent them from getting the
money
actually helped them get it it's
absolutely stunning stuff and as i've
said before
when you don't even have an agreement as
to
not what the facts are but what
facts are meaning what is a fact and
what is an opinion
when you don't even have agreement there
and understanding on that
uh people will fall for anything and
that explains donald trump
and it explains so much of what we've
seen over the last five years
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
ten different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
slash pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video